Now I want to draw my attention
Away from the madness that is happening in Europe
I go to a place very far from them
To one of the French colonies in the Caribbean
Namely St. Dominguez
I know that I write words wrongly
But St. Domingue, now called Haiti
Is the western half of the island of Hispaniola
Which Columbus found for the first time
When he discovered the new world
The eastern part of the island
Which you can not see here
Because I grew up on the western half
The eastern section is now called the Dominican Republic
It was called St. Domingue
It was under the control of Spain
Let me write down what you said
So here is Spain
You probably do not see the yellow color well
France colonized this aspect
I will write Spain more clearly
Spain occupied the eastern part of the island
France colonized the western half.
Let us move on now
To 1492 when Columbus appeared
It was a Spanish colony
Now I am talking about the western side only
The eastern side continued to be a Spanish colony
In 1697, the western section was officially given to France
It was a Spanish colony until then
And from 1697 to the period
Which we are talking about now
The end of the eighteenth century
The period of the French Revolution
The western half was a French colony
French colony
You probably ask .. you know ..
All this madness happens in France
Kings fall, people are executed with guillotine
There is a war with all empires
Why are they moving all this way to this side of the world?
And focus on this small island?
Well, the big answer or I think the main answer
Especially from the point of view of the French
There are other historical reasons
I think it is relevant
But the main reason is that St. Domingue was in this period
The most - let me write this -
The most profitable slave colony in the world
In the world
These colonists
They care about profit most of their time
To a great degree in history
This is their interest
But you have to think about it
Remember, what precipitated the French Revolution
Or, I believe, was the main factor
That France was bankrupt
The bankruptcy of France
So you have this small island here
Which is considered a slave colony
Their farms produce tons of cane sugar
A business produces huge profits
Nothing happens in St. Domingo
France will be embroiled in bankruptcy
And not just bankrupt
But also because of those wars
With almost everyone in Europe
So let us remind ourselves
That is happening in France
He will return to France
So in 1789
You have been invited by the legislature
People in the third district were upset
So they met at the tennis court
And called themselves the National Council
They took the tennis court
In fact they called themselves the National National Assembly
Then they were driven out of the room
Then they had to do tennis
There they promised to make a constitution
They began to talk about freedom and brotherhood
And that all men were created equal
All these great ideas of enlightenment
And in the time of all this
There was a businessman named Vincent Oger
I do not know if I'm writing it right
He was a rich, mixed-race man - let me write this -
He was mixed race, he had a quarter of an African descent
And three-quarters of them are of French origin
It was in Paris for work
And when there was, the French Revolution
And the call of the legislature
Have begun
He said: I know what?
I am a rich and educated man
I own land, in what is now called Haiti
But it was St. Domingue at that time
In fact, he had slaves
I would like to be clear about this
He also had slaves
His tongue says: I am good as all these
Europeans around me
But I do not get equal rights for them
But all these great things happen
With a talk about a new constitution
Let me delve deeper into this.
So he had put pressure with many people
Thinkers
Pressure for equal rights began
Such as the right to vote
And not treated as a second class person.
At first they were ignored.
The National Assembly wanted to do good things
But they do not want to do anything too much
As a rich and educated man
As a man equal to them
So they refused.
But in March of 1790
The National Assembly has amended
Provides that all landlords must
- There are other things -
They must be active citizens.
Mr. Vincent Oger and his assistants said
It is their victory
This is the wording that tells us
That any man possesses
- I own land, I am the owner -
Must be an active citizen
Giving us the right to vote
So I declare that this is a victory for his rights
And to people who have the same rights
He returned to St. Domingue
He said to the governor see
All this madness is happening in France
We have the National Assembly
They gave me the right to vote
Unfortunately, the governor ignored him
He did not listen to him
He did not listen to what he wanted to say
He said he did not care what was happening in France
I will not give you
People like you have the right to vote
He did not like the governor's response
Everything seemed to be in his favor
Even the National Assembly in his favor
But the governor ignored him
So he started a revolution when he returned
He was treated harshly
He returned in October 1790, ignored by the governor
So he started a revolution
Unfortunately, it did not succeed
I would like to be clear
When the revolution began, its aim was not to abolish slavery
He did not dare to give black men on the island
Right to vote
But rebelled to give free men
Who have the right to vote
This was his problem in the revolution.
I want to give you an idea of ​​the demographic structure
Of St. Domingo at the time
There were 500,000 slaves of African descent
There were 40,000 white colonists
In addition to 28 thousand mixed race, free men
Of different races or as you want to describe them
If you want to start a revolution
To defend your rights only
You will need some of these 28 thousand
Against 40,000 well-armed.
If you think it
Perhaps I should speak in a broader sense
He was trying to become part of this club
But if he tried to talk a little broader
Maybe you could have patted
On one of those 500 thousand anxious
But he did not, so his revolution did not work
It was caught
In February 1791 he was executed
All this was futile
He went through all these problems for some freedom
Was ignored, began a revolution
That revolution did not succeed
He was executed
But he began to influence consciousness
People of African descent
His revolution has led
To what will happen in the years to come
Unclearly
But it happened and he was the first person
Who tried to start a revolution mainly
But anyway, after he was executed
People began to grumble
Especially in the north
Most sugar farms were in the north
More farms mean more profit
There was a juggling ceremony
Which were performed individually
The name of the charlatan Dati Buckman
I searched for his pictures but found nothing
Unfortunately there are no photos of him
This man was running the ceremony of sorcery
Which instigated the slave uprising in Haiti
Or what is now called Haiti but formerly St. Dominguez
Now remember and look at the demographic structure
You can imagine
If slaves rise
Against everyone on the island
You can imagine
They will not be very regular
Or they are armed like others
Just because of their absolute number - will perform well
And in August 1791
The rebellion of all slaves began
You can imagine how much this frightens France
Put all the things of the revolution aside
And new concepts of enlightenment
Here is the most profitable colony in the world
Suddenly a revolution breaks out
People on both sides are being killed
The farmer is burning
And from the point of view of the Government of France
All this will adversely affect their profits
Because France is bankrupt as you remember
And engaged in wars with other States
So she sent a delegation
He is subordinate to this man
His name
- I know I write words wrongly -
Sonthanax
I do not know what is the best way to pronounce
He had 6,000 or 7,000 soldiers
They were sent from France
To end the slave rebellion
To bring things back to normal
And to make everyone
Along with France here
France in April 1792 - Let me write this -
The Legislative Assembly may recall,
Which had prepared a new constitution
Which involves a new legislative assembly
They gave full citizenship
For free men of different races
Unfortunately, it was Vincent Oger
Somewhat premature
He only waited several years
There was no need for revolution
Or that he has contributed to this
So it's not clear
It could be his revolution
Led to the slave revolution
Which has contributed to
Make the National Assembly reconcile with the idea
Perhaps it may make it happen
Or it will happen anyway
Because they made free people citizens
They probably did it.
You can look at it from both positive and negative sides
The positive sidebar was
It is compatible with the idea
Enlightenment and Revolution
Though you want a strategic look
Maybe they say
That all this madness is happening in Haiti
If at least we can bring them to our side
We will be able
People are probably suppressed here
Let us be clearer
Many people are free of mixed races
They own slaves themselves
It is in their own interest
They were similar to white colonists
In Sant Domingo at that time
If they are strategic on the subject
Perhaps to become somewhat
From the integration of free men's forces on the island
Or landowners on the island
But they sent that message with Sonthanax and six or seven thousand soldiers
To restore things to their nature
You can remember
That this made many men unhappy on the island
Because some colonists at that time
They were not the most liberal thinkers
They probably did not appreciate this idea
That all free men from all the various races receive the same rights
So there was hostility against this man
Against Sonthanax here
It is possible to remember that in February 1793
- We saw in the previous video or in several previous videos -
In February 1793, France began a war with Great Britain
Britain has control here
This is Jamaica
To be clear, Green is St. Domingue
Here is Santo Domingo
Which is controlled by Spain
So you have a big problem
There is Sonthanax here
He fights some eggs
He tries to suppress the slave rebellion
Or at least bring things back to normal
Suddenly the British come here
You have many white colonies
Which makes him say that if France goes so
We will stand by the British
We will stand next to the British
Or they will help us
We will use that assistance from the British
To restore our way in St. Domingo
As far as I can tell that Sonthanax
He had a conviction in emancipation
He was sympathetic to people
Of mixed races
And even to the plight of slaves themselves
And also for strategic reasons
He thought that bad things would happen
He told himself that he had 500 thousand slaves
We want to repel the British
This is a bold reaction
In the history of slavery
This is rather one of the most important announcements
In 1793, in August of 1793
It is likely to be a reflection of his own ideas
Or because of the threat to Britain
Sonthanax declares slavery to all slaves
Did not say that they would get equal rights
For men who own land
But it eliminates slavery
He did it at first only in the north
But in September and October
So extended it included
All French property is in Sant Domingo
Now you can imagine
The slaves who were revolting all this time
Somewhat suspicious of this man
It looks like it sends to St. Domingo
Or what is now called Haiti, to quell the uprising
He appeared with 6 or 7 thousand soldiers
Try to stand by the enemies of the slaves
To quell the uprising
Suddenly
When Britain emerged as a threat
His tongue was saying that he ended slavery himself
I now declare the end of slavery
But the people had been deceived before and say
That's just a trick
Only to make us shaken
So they can come back to us
Their leaders were skeptical about this
But in February 1794, the order was confirmed
Ad certified
By the French National Convention
With time, they began to spread to liberated slaves
Or rather the rebel slaves on the island
In May 1794, the commander of the slave slaves
- This name is very important -
Toussaint Louverture
He was the rebel leader
He was a former self-taught slave
He has proven himself repeatedly
As one of the best military generals
And throughout history
In Mayom of 1794, Toussaint Loftur decided
- I will write his name again -
Decided to join the French Republic
Sonthanax side
Let's look at the numbers again
You have Tucan Louvretor
He is the leader
For these 500 thousand slave editors
This is the island's army
He is now the commander of the island
Now you can look at it
The general or ruler of the island, to this colony
Despite having good leadership qualities
He had a paranoid side to himself
That is why he declared himself ruler of life
In 1801, he issued a Basic Law
He declares himself to be the ruler of life
They are also in his protection
This was not the unusual thing at that time
I mean if you look across the Atlantic
See what Napoleon is doing
It is the Republic of France
He declares himself emperor
And not what for life
These people say I have the same right to do so
I was the leader of these people to their freedom
They trusted me
So I will declare myself a ruler of life
And also her protector
As well as being preceded by a step forward
The rest of the rulers of his time
He had not only had tactics cut and burned
In fact there is discipline
Among all his forces
We will see some of his close men, Disallin
- I know I write it wrongly -
It was more brutal with people
Who is fighting against them
Unlike the discipline of Tusan Louverture
When he came to power
He did not try revenge
On people of mixed races and on the owners of white farms
He realized this and said to himself: Do you know?
We are new people
Officials for the new state
- or it is a new state in his mind -
But let us try not to make a challenge
Let us try to preserve our society
He walks in a reasonable way
So as not to destroy ourselves in oblivion
France has yet to be declared independent
This is also an important point
He did not want to be completely separated from France
So no independence
He was happy
Being part of the French Empire
But he will nevertheless be the ruler
You can imagine it on two levels
Napoleon was not happy
In 1799 and specifically in 1800
Napoleon came to power, calling himself the first chancellor
Napoleon is not happy
He is not happy for two reasons
The first is that cocky man
Who claims to be the ruler of life on the island
No one can do that except Napoleon
The other problem is
He had lost 500,000 slaves suddenly
They are now free men
He should pay them better wages
Rather than making them do what you want
And take all the profits
The island, the colony has become much less profitable
A voice in his mind tells him
To restore slavery
And you will find that it was later explicitly refuted
So he does not like the freedom of slaves
That is why he sent his son-in-law
If there is a dirty task to complete
You should send a man you trust
That is why he sent his son-in-law Charles Leclerc
With 40,000 troops
That is why Napoleon takes the situation seriously
To recover the island
From Tucson to Louvreur
Imagine that huge battle
Which takes place on the island of Sant Domingo
On the western half of the island
Which is controlled by France
This is why it was useful to them
But Tusan Louverture did not benefit
That some of his close generals or close aides
Bear in mind that bad things will happen
When they saw that this man
- which I will talk about in the next video -
When they saw his barbaric actions
But some of the generals of Tusan Louverture
They started with the possibility that bad things would happen
And they turned against him
He was one of them
Has actually completed the revolution
But when he was fighting for Tusan Louverture
- This is John Jacques Desaline -
He and some men
Close to Tusan Louverture
Join Leclerc
Leclerc makes it look like
He is not trying to restore slavery
He is not trying to take citizenship
Of people of African descent
Makes it look like
Trying to stop Tucan Louverture
And this man said, Well
In order to improve St. Dominghe I will be with you
At that time was Toussaint Louverture
In a difficult position
And he said to him, Let your lord be blessed
Let us have some negotiations
Perhaps we can find a way
To make you and it is with you
Within Napoleon's empire
- which now turns into Napoleon's empire -
So Tosan stayed for Lovertor
He stood alone
A man of honor who trusted people said
Tarles Leclerc must also be a decent man
So he met him to discuss that
But for Charles Leclerc turned
He was not a fair man
I think I must draw a demon horn on it
When Tusan appeared to Lofttor
For a civilized meeting
He brought some men to arrest him and catch him
He then sent him by boat to France
Toussaint Louverture died
In captivity in France
I will stop at this point now
It is a rather sad moment
You have temporary freedom for slaves
You have this important historical man Toussaint Louverture
Lead the slaves
Trying to establish a new government
But it turns into a violent surprise
Because of Napoleon's faithful follower
Because of Charles Leclerc, who is his son-in-law
I will finish the video now
An article by Tusan Lovertor
Because it will warn
What will happen in the next video
This argument
He said it after being caught on the boat heading for France
Let me clarify the statement here
"By overthrowing me, you did not cut into St. Domingue
Sawa trunk of freedom.
It will be reborn from the roots
Because they are many and because they are deep. "